han pasado Ya dos meses desde que
comenzaron las protestas en Irán y en
los dos últimos días se han reactivado
estas movilizaciones no solamente con
huelgas generales sino también con
protestas en muchas ciudades del país y
esto no solamente es para recordar a
maxam Y esa joven kurda que fue detenida
por la policía de la moral y dos horas
después llevada a un hospital con muerte
cerebral sino también para recordar a
más de 300 personas algunas personas
hablan de 1.500 que murieron durante o
fueron asesinadas durante las protestas
de 2019 ayer hubo 15 muertos en todo el
país 7 de ellos en la región del juze
están en el suroccidente del país en la
ciudad de isé donde siete personas
murieron entre ellos un niño que se
encontraba con su padre y las
autoridades acusan a grupos terroristas
de estar detrás de estos ataques
mientras que las personas locales dicen
que fueron las autoridades iraníes las
que llevaron a estos asesinatos sin
embargo dos milicianos murieron lo que
complica aún más la situación el
ministro de relaciones exteriores iraní
hizo un trino en el cual acusa a
occidente a Estados Unidos y al llamado
estado de Israel como él lo dice de
estar detrás de estas protestas
queriendo dividir a Irán esto también
llegan un momento en el cual la
sentencias de muerte empiezan a aparecer
en esos juicios rápidos que está
llevando a cabo la justicia en anís son
cinco personas sin embargo ellos podrían
apelar pero aquí en Irán piensan que
este tipo de sentencias llegarán más y
más tratando de mandar un mensaje a la
población para que no salga la calle a
seguir prote